foreign
[Music]
economy continues to show resilience in
a challenging Global context declining
Energy prices
diversification of energy Supply and
reduced consumption have contained the
adverse economic impact of Russia's war
of aggression against Ukraine following
a marginal contraction of economic
activity at the end of 2022 an estimate
that the small Rebound in the first
quarter of this year indicates that the
EU has managed to avoid recession
as lower energy prices continue to
provide relief to households and firms
budgets the economic expansion is
expected to continue in 2023 and pick up
some Pace in 24.
headline inflation is set to fall
gradually and core inflation is proving
persistent so further tightening of
financing conditions is still expected
Weighing on economic activity
after hitting new records for employment
and unemployment rates the labor market
is set to remain strong
and wage growth is likely to accelerate
the EU General government deficit is
expected to decrease over the forecast
Horizon however several member states
are still set to seize their deficits
increase in 2023
while fears of a recession have faded
economic uncertainty is still high and
we must remain vigilant
foreign